l' affaire grégory revient à la une de
l'actualité après sept ans d'instruction
l'hebdomadaire le point publient dans
son nouveau numéro le réquisitoire
définitif du procureur général de dijon
il conclut à l'innocence de christine
villemin la mère de grégory commentaires
isabelle thomas
christine villemin innocenté telle est
la conclusion du procureur général de
dijon
dans son réquisitoire définitif que
publie l'hebdomadaire le point à
paraître demain
il ne résulte pas de charges suffisantes
à l'encontre de christine villemin
d'avoir commis le crime d'assassinât
dont elle a été inculpée conclu le
procureur
christine villemin était inculpée depuis
ce soir du réaction d'un avocat
particulièrement satisfaits cela va de
soi de savoir qu'après cinq années
d'instruction à dijon c'est à dire cinq
années après qu'il y ait eu ce
supplément d'information à dijon
l'erreur judiciaire et redresser et nous
nous acheminons maintenant avec un degré
de certitude vers l'innocence de
christine villemin
huit ans après la mort du petit grégory
il appartiendra à la chambre
d'accusation de dijon de rendre une
décision définitive
le 21 septembre prochain